POISE.
THEY PASSED IT BACK AND FORTH. .
NAZEM KADRI.
GOT LOOSE. GIRARD AND
MAKAR HAVE REALLY FORMED A NICE
COMBINAT SO HARD.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE ONE REAL --
LANDESKOG, THAT'S WHAT MAKES
THIS LINE SO INCREDIBLY
DIFFNY TEAM IN
PETER McNAB BACK IN THE ONE OF N
>> TURNOVER, SCORE!
GOODNESSEHIND THEIR OWN
NET.
>> THE AVS DO SOMETHING THERE TS
ARE MOVING THE PUCK IN AMPER.
>> WELL, THIS -- THE SCORE OF
THE GAME IS 1-1 BECAUSE THE
DARAR AGAIN.
KREBS TAKING WHAT THEY GIVE HIM.
ERIK J BUFFALO.
THEY CERTAINLY ARE PETE. HOLD O.
[ WHISTLE ]
>> AND
>> THE AVS ARE FINA
GOOD SHOT.AT'S THE AVALANCHE PL.
THAT'S WHERE THE HAND PASS IS
GONNA COME INTO RIGHT EVER.BACKE
SCORES!
T,
WATCH THIS POWERPLAY AND HOW HE.
HANG ON.
POWERPLAY.
>> FOR THE AVALANCHE, WE'VE SEE
THE BOARDS.
GOOD JOB THERE BY NAZEM KADRI TA
WE'LL TAKE A TIME- CALE.
GLOVES IT DOWN.
AVS STILLIMETER LIKE
THIS, THAT'S NOT BEFORE YOU WANT
COULD NOT GO TO LANDESKOG.
HE WILL GLOVE IT DOWN.
POPPED OFF F
POWERPLAY.
>> WELL, OF AVALANCHE DID A LOT
OF THINGS RIGHT BUT FOR THE
FITZGERALD.
HEAD MAN PA
>> HERE'S THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
BUFFALO.
THEE STOLEN BY
O'CONNOR AND HE
ABSOLUTELY E E